similar to tennis when you're saying
like golf needs to be [ __ ] crazy
again yeah I feel like tennis is about
to be like Nick kyrgos I love that guy
he's the only one who's actually [ __ ]
I love that guy why just because of his
attitude yeah I love it like it's
frustrating to me because it's like okay
you're not as good as you probably could
be because your attitude kind of sucks
yeah but at the same time it's like he's
bringing that edge
he's making it exciting yeah he is it's
fun to watch him he's also he's a kind
of a Blue's Cannon a little bit he
doesn't give a [ __ ] about the rules no
and he has tats he's sick as [ __ ] is
that tats those are tats right
sick
[Laughter]
is totted up sick as [ __ ] nah I actually
met the doll I don't [ __ ] with that guy
no tops I don't have any tattoos yet oh
yeah you have tattoos yeah am I sick as
[ __ ]
you don't have like a full sleeve
someone commented the other day it was
like your tattoos I mean I got a lot of
negative comments about the tattoos yeah
but someone was like why because they're
just they're dumb and I understand that
they're dumb yeah my body my temple kind
of thing what I've never heard that like
I don't get tattoos because my body's a
temple oh yeah you're saying with people
like that comment now they're just like
they're just like someone was like Hey
man the placement of your tattoos looks
looks really bad like you should fill in
the rest of your arm
oh I don't that doesn't make and I'm
kind of well these are stupid like it's
just
but you're gonna fill it in eventually I
actually probably will I'll probably do
the rest of my arm just because it does
look pretty stupid
like it looks like uh like when you go
to when you used to go to you know a
restaurant as a kid and they would have
flash seats or whatever no that what
like those little like stickers no I'm
saying when like the the tablecloth was
like you could draw on it yeah you know
that's kind of what my arm looks like
what do they mean is there is there any
that hold any real value well this one
that says mom right in a heart that
one's for my mom got it okay this one
the flower one that was uh we were in
New Zealand on tour and uh Kelsey was
getting a tattoo she had she had like
hit up this artist the artist was like
Hey I'm a fan you should come in and get
a tattoo and so Kelsey had this like
Thin Line idea that she wanted and so we
go in the place and while she gets a
tattoo this other guy that owned the
studio his name was Triton's the seventh
I think he's a super famous tattoo
artist this guy like invented this style
of thin line flowers that's the sickest
name I've ever heard in my life can you
try and pull him up on Instagram maybe
like go to who I'm following and search
it's like Triton I think is his name try
in the seventh yeah something like that
damn as far as I understand this guy
kind of like pioneered this style of
thin line flower tattoos that like are
really popular amongst women like women
will fly like his his client the
previous day was a girl that flew from
Calgary to New Zealand just to get this
tattoo and then fly back so this is like
people are spending tens of thousands of
dollars to get this tattoo style done
see girls will get like their entire
body tattoo that's sick
and anyways he was like he was like oh
bro I'm a fan and I have some time while
Kelsey's getting a tattoo do you want
one and I was like [ __ ] yeah let's go
and he was like I'll do my style but
I'll make it a little bit darker to
match the rest of your arm and I was
like cool he like draws something up and
puts it on my arm and it's like a full
half sleeve and I was like dude and
that's always like a really awkward
conversation at a tattoo studio when
they put the stencil on and you're not
like fully happy with it yeah and you're
like this is going on my body forever
but I don't want to like insult maybe
it's just the Canadian enemy yeah I'm
like I really don't like confrontation I
don't want to insult this guy
yeah an artist of this caliber so I was
like bro I don't know if I want to get a
half sleeve today like can you make it a
little bit smaller he's like oh yeah no
problem
um that's how he sells oh he's New
Zealand
my problem there there it is now you
problem so he put this he put this one
on my arm and uh and I got it I [ __ ]
love it but that's that's I like tattoos
that like are associated with memories
like that yeah it just feels cool that I
can look at that be like oh I was that
was when I was in New Zealand New
Zealand for work like I was on tour and
I got to do a show in New Zealand that's
like the coolest thing ever there's a
cool story behind it yeah this one was
also a tour it was like me and the whole
tour crew besides one person got this
it's like magnifying glass it was like a
stupid ass joke that we would say on
tour who's uh who's the person who
didn't get it Noelle didn't get it and
because he didn't doesn't have any
tattoos I think he wants to get one
eventually but at that point didn't have
any so didn't get it and then I think
our
I forget who else didn't get it our
lighting guy or something but the rest
of us did yeah what if I just now I was
in West Virginia
[Laughter]
and for my final gift surprise a part of
the group what the [ __ ] dude you weren't
even on top
um and then this one so my dad uh when I
was a kid he broke the world record for
the longest distance traveled in 24
hours by human power
walking no he was on a bike okay he
engineered a recumbent bicycle which is
like a lay down bike yeah and rode it
around a track it had a shell around it
too and he wrote it on a track for 24
hours straight like only stopped twice
to take a [ __ ] I'm pretty sure holy [ __ ]
and broke the world world record he was
in the Guinness Book of World Records
one year like I used to get that book
every year for Christmas as a kid and
then one year my dad was a full color
picture of my dad standing beside the
bike how did he [ __ ] coolest thing
ever for a child did they show up to the
track and like watch him do it uh no he
had I think there was someone there from
Guinness he just lied yeah yeah no he
didn't actually do it no there was
someone there I think from Guinness but
yeah the the submission process is like
a formal thing you have to like submit
and have proof and all that [ __ ] and he
attempted it a couple times failed and
then finally did it and anyways his bike
was called critical power the logo was a
skull so that's why I have three skulls
tattoos well no wonder you're a [ __ ]
beast when it comes to running swimming
well that's like part of the reason why
it like it makes me happy because I feel
like it's kind of in my blood yeah it's
like I was raised around it and seeing
it so much so now it feels kind of like
I was meant to do it yeah